ahora que ya sabemos un poquito acerca
del calor de formación y el cambio de la
entropía y que es la entropía de chopo
van podemos hablar de la ley de hesse ok
es de la ley de hesse y lo que nos dice
es que el cambio la energía de un
proceso es independiente de cómo
llegamos de un estado a otro ok y
realmente esto es debido a 'la al hecho
de que la energía es una variable de
estado cuando hemos hablado del entalpía
o de la energía interna son variables de
estado y hemos hablado de esto muchas
veces que es independiente de como como
recordamos la trayectoria de un estado a
otro pero esto es bastante útil para
cuando trabajamos en las reacciones de
todos los días así que déjenme poner una
reacción de la forma a más ve que nos
produce no se hace más de
y lo que quiero descubrir es cuál fue el
cambio en la entalpía de esta reacción
no esencialmente cuánto calor fue
absorbido o liberado por esta reacción y
no sé cuáles no lo he medido y todo lo
que tengo son los los calores de
formación de tanto los reactivos como en
los productos por ejemplo aquí digamos
que tengo el calor de formación
recordemos que h no es de calor en
inglés sino h se refiere al cambio en la
entalpía ok entonces cuál es el delta h
de formación a temperatura y presión
estándar ok eso es en la temperatura y
presión estándar entonces vamos a verlo
en alguna tabla para ver cuáles también
necesitamos tener el calor de formación
de h déjenme ponerlo así con un ave ok
calor de formación de idea
estándar y también vamos a obtener el
calor de formación de ce aunque el
camión lenta al pia y también el calor
de formación desde así que todas estas
cosas las podemos ver en una tabla y lo
vamos a ver en un segundo ahora lo que
la ley deje es nos dice es que el cambio
la energía el camión perdonen la
entalpía es lo que estamos viendo aquí
el cambio en la entalpía es
independiente de lo que hacemos así que
en vez de ver sólo esta reacción y mirar
vamos vamos a hacer esto vamos vamos a
regresar nos a los a los dos a la forma
elemental de estos reactivos ok por
ejemplo si tuviéramos dióxido de carbono
nos vamos al carbón y al oxígeno así que
realmente nos regresamos a la forma
elemental y cuánta energía o cuál es el
cambio entalpía de regresar a la forma
elemental a la formación el calor de
formación para ahí para ver
en su forma cuando regresamos a su forma
elemental en realidad lleva un signo
menos verdad porque vamos en sentido
contrario así que este cambio
simplemente nos va a tomar
- delta h o el calor de formación de a
ok podría ser el menos puede ser
realmente el calor de construcción es
decir de a la hora de romper ahí ve en
sus formas elementales ok y podemos ir
ahora de su forma elemental de vuelta a
los productos porque tenemos los mismos
átomos sólo se están reajustando en
distintos conjuntos de moléculas así que
podemos irnos de la forma elemental
hacia los productos y sabemos cuáles son
verdad sabemos cuánta energía se
necesita para formarse y de así que la
ley deje es nos dice es que delta h de
esta reacción el cambio en la entropía
delta h de esta reacción el cambio la
entropía de esta reacción es
esencialmente va a ser la suma de lo que
toma descanso
descomponer a ive en su forma elemental
más lo que se requiere para formarse y
de ok entonces eso se produce a delta h
el calor de formación de se más del
tache de formación desde ok son los
calores de formación de seis y hay que
restarle hay que restarle el calor de
descomposición de a
y el calor de formación o de
descomposición debe ok ok y si es
negativo podríamos liberar energía si es
positivo significa que hay más energía
aquí del lado de los productos que de
los reactivos y por lo tanto necesita
absorber energía y es en dos térmica
todo esto es abstracto y todo esto que
hemos dicho es la ley de que es así que
vamos a aplicarlo a algunos problemas
digamos que tengo esta reacción de aquí
donde empiezo con amoniaco y es amoniaco
en su forma gaseosa y vamos a hacerlo
reaccionar con oxígeno y atómico gaseoso
para producir monóxido de nitrógeno
cuatro moles de eso y seis moles de agua
así que lo que hacemos aquí es mirar los
calores de formación de todos estos de
todas estas moléculas así que cuál es el
calor de formación del amoniaco y esto
siempre está dado en kilo jules por mol
ok eso es lo que lo que se requiere para
formar un molde amoniaco
ok esto lo obtuvimos de wikipedia está
en inglés pero como está en su forma
gaseosa de gm como como el amoniaco está
en su forma gaseosa simplemente miramos
este de aquí
ok así que su calor de formación es
menos 45.9 por kilo jules por mol que
eso es menos 49 menos 49 perdón 45.9 ok
eso es lo que se requiere para formar un
molde amoniaco aunque hay kilo jules
cuál es el calor de formación del
oxígeno bueno como realmente el oxígeno
ya está en su forma elemental entonces
si vemos algo en su en algo si vemos
algo que está en su forma elemental su
calor de formación es cero así que si
ves todos su calor de formación es cero
si ves hidrógeno digamos h2 su calor de
formación es cero si ves carbón solito
su calor de formación es cero
ahora qué pasa con el monóxido de
nitrógeno vamos a ver eso
dónde está el monóxido de nitrógeno ahí
está ok su calor de formación es 90 29
positivo
90 punto 29 90 punto 29 y cuál es la
formación el calor de formación del agua
vamos a ver agua
ok es
en su forma líquida es menos 285 punto
menos menos 285 punto 83
ahora podrías estar tentado a decir que
la ley de gente nos dice que si sumamos
los delta h del lado derecho y restamos
los deltas el lado izquierdo ya acabamos
no estaría mal estaría es casi cierto
pero lo tendrías incorrecto porque estos
son los calores de formación por mol y
aquí por ejemplo tenemos cuatro de
amoniaco 5 de oxígeno 4 de monóxido de
nitrógeno y 6 de agua así que tenemos
que multiplicar esto por el número de
moles así que esto lo tenemos que
multiplicar por 4 ok
tenemos que multiplicar aquí por 4 y
aquí por 6 no te no hay que multiplicar
el 0 por 5 verdad porque nos va a dar 0
ahora aplicamos la ley de gestha para
determinar quién es delta h de la
reacción así que la delta h de la
reacción el cambio en la entropía de
esta reacción va a ser igual a 4 por 90
punto 29 ok 4 por
90 punto 29 más seis veces el calor de
formación del agua que es más 6 x menos
285 punto 83 ok solo como nota parte
esto es positivo esto para el monóxido
de nitrógeno es positivo quiere decir
que necesitas meterle calor al sistema
para que se pueda formar esta molécula
verdad aunque no solo va a ocurrir por
si mismo y para el agua por otro lado
libera calor así que de alguna forma es
más estable pero bueno estos son los
calores de formación de los productos y
hay que restarle el calor de formación
de los reactivos de los reactivos de
esta reacción así que hay que quitarle 4
por 45.9
y ahí hay que tomar en cuenta el signo
menos
ok y eso fue para el amoniaco aquí tenía
un menos hay que contar bien los signos
así que con que nos quedamos déjenme
sacar la calculadora así que déjenme
ponerlo aquí
necesito leer así que voy a dejarlo
fuera de la pantalla es que ya se está
llenando verdad así que vamos a dejarlo
aquí entonces tenemos 4 x 90 puntos 29 +
seis veces 285 punto 83 negativo y eso
nos da menos 1300 53.82 hasta ahora
suena más o menos correcto no y ahora
hay que restarle 4 veces menos 45.9 así
que le restamos menos 4 x
- 45.9 verdad aquí va el menos y eso nos
da me menos mil 170 así que nuestro
cambio la entropía de estas reacciones
menos mil 170 kilos jules para esta
reacción para esta reacción y todo lo
que hicimos fue tomar el calor de
formación de los productos multiplicarlo
por el número de moles y restarle el
calor de formación de los reactivos ahí
lo tienes vamos a hacer uno más de éstos
digamos que tengo algo de propano aunque
tenemos propano y vamos a hacerlo hacer
una combustión al oxidar lo y nos va a
dar dióxido de carbono y agua así que
cuál es el calor de formación de propano
vamos a mirarlo aquí es es bastante
sorprendente que tan extensiva es esta
lista verdad del propano aquí lo tenemos
es menos 104.7
ok vamos a escribirlo - 104.7
y el calor de formación del oxígeno que
está en su estado elemental pues
simplemente va a ser cero el calor de
formación del dióxido de carbono déjeme
ver el vioxx dióxido de carbono como
gases menos 393 punto 5 menos 393 punto
5 y el agua ya habíamos sacado eso es
menos 285 punto menos 285 punto 83 así
que cuánto calor es se forma cuando
hacemos combustión de esto así que vamos
a ver tenemos que determinar el calor de
los productos multiplicarlo por su por
el número de moles que en este caso es 3
ok porque obtuvimos 3 de estos por cada
mol liberamos esta cantidad de energía y
hay que multiplicarlo por 4 el del agua
y después sumarlo y luego restar una vez
el del propano así que obtenemos tenemos
tres veces 390 y 3.5
y de hecho ese es negativo
4 x 285 puntos 83 83 y que también es
negativo y eso nos da menos 2300 23.82 y
luego hay que restarle una vez menos
104.7 que es lo mismo que sólo sumarle
104 104.7 así que sumamos 104.7 y eso
nos da menos 2.200 19.12 así que
esencialmente el cambio en lento en la
instancia de las reacciones es igual a
menos 2.219 ok cuando vamos en esta
dirección del propano con el oxígeno al
dióxido de carbono y agua así que por
cada molde propano vamos a producir esta
cantidad de energía y esto de aquí
es más o menos lo que produce es 2.200
kilos jules ok
así que esencialmente esta reacción todo
lo que hemos hecho es agregar déjenme
hacerlo por ejemplo esto lo podríamos
reescribir de esta forma el propano + 5
oxígenos nos da 3 bio dióxido de carbono
más cuatro aguas más dos mil 219 kilos
eso es lo que se liberó de esta reacción
es exotérmica de este lado de la
reacción tiene menos calor que del lado
de los reactivos así que no sólo
desaparece sólo se libera ok sólo se
libera ahora algunas veces vemos algunas
preguntas donde dice hey muy bien ya ya
viste cómo se comporta esta reacción
pero a lo mejor queremos saber qué
ocurre si tenemos 33 gramos de propano
33 gramos de propano bueno entonces
vamos a pensar cuántos moles de propano
hay en 33 gramos ok y haremos una
conversión para ver cuánto obtenemos del
calor así que cuánto pesa un molde de
propano tenemos es un mol
un mol de carbón que pesa 12 gramos y un
molde de hidrógeno pesa un gramo así que
un mal un molde propano va a pesar 3
veces el del carbón porque tenemos de 3
y 8 veces el del hidrógeno así que esto
es 36 + 8
así que va a ser 44 esto va a ser 44
gramos por mol de propano déjenme
escribir eso 44 gramos por mol ahora si
nos dan 33 gramos cuántos moles vamos a
tener buenos y tenemos 33 gramos por
podríamos escribir así 1 sobre 44 mol
sobre gramo se cancelan los gramos
cancelamos los gramos y simplemente me
quedan 33 entre 44 que eso es punto 75
moles 33 gramos son igual a tres cuartos
de mol así que vamos a producir tres
cuartos de esta de este calor así que si
multiplicamos esto por punto 75 esto por
punto 75 que son tres cuartos obtenemos
menos mil 664 así que si esto lo
multiplicamos por punto 75 nos da menos
mil 664 o bien mil 664 del lado derecho
ok si nos dan un mol liberamos 2200
esencialmente kilo jules ahora si nos
dan 33 gramos de propano que es tres
cuartos de un mod
entonces nos va a liberar más o menos
1.600 kilos jules de cualquier forma
espero que haya sido útil